it became very common especially amongst
sophisticates who had not been early on
the lab leak issue
to declare what does it matter
uh we're stuck with this virus now let's
just deal with it and the answer is
actually a few things matter more
the obvious reason is that to the extent
that this is the product of a laboratory
accident
knowing how that could possibly have
happened so that we can prevent it is
essential but that's obvious
what i think is not obvious is how much
harm was likely done by that route
and this is why we have to get this
right so
couple points
um
one
i believe and i hope that we are
ultimately able to get past all of the
people who want to prevent
an honest exploration
uh i believe that what we had was a
brief period of time after sars kovi ii
emerged in the world
in which we really could have driven it
to extinction just as sarsko v1
effectively is extinct right
it seems to have driven itself to
extinction right it did not have it
didn't have the the the goods to keep
going and the question is could we have
delivered sarskovi to sufficient
disadvantage in transmitting if we had
gotten to it early and had taken the
politics out of it could we have driven
it to extinction and i believe what we
now know suggests that we probably could
have right or that failing that we could
have driven it to a state
uh of extreme rarity where it's
effectively extinct like rabies in the
first world
um so
if that is true if what happened was
however this thing emerged into the
world let's assume the best let's assume
uh it was research that it was
well-intentioned research rather than
dual-purpose weapons research let's
assume they were trying to figure out
they were really afraid of
pathogen getting into the world
of a particular nature they wanted to
study it so that they would be ahead of
the game when it happened and they
goofed and it escaped right that's still
a terrible story and i believe
uh likely the pathogen never would have
made the jump no pathogen like the one
that they were looking at would have
made the jump and become a pandemic
so the point is everything that happens
negative as a result of that jump having
been made with human assistance
goes on the bill of the people who made
the error
in judgment but
before you go but um
which is part of why i think it's so
important for the messaging coming from
those people and the people whose side
they are on
uh to convince the world that it has a
synthetic origin basically it it
furthers you know it
they could not be responsible for
something asymptotic origin but it also
helps keep the population in fear oh my
god at any moment in in a in a world
that is populated as we are where we're
constantly going into wilderness areas
and running into animals ooh scary
animals then um at any moment we could
have another one of these things we'd
better keep things clean we'd better
trust the authorities we'd better
you know get the public health policy
you know and and you know what the who
is working on right now is ridiculously
scary and it um you know they are
actually playing on people's fear that
they have that this entire situation has
created in order to move forward a you
know authoritarian mandate that
potentially has the capacity to
undermine um sovereign governments
this goes squarely back to what we
discussed last week
with the fact that the um the mechanism
of procuring grants has turned all sorts
of people that we need to do objective
science into salesmen they don't even
necessarily understand that that's what
they've become right it is so reflexive
and so in effect there is a
section of each of the grants that goes
towards such research that says
something akin to
you know as the human population expands
we are coming into more and more contact
with wildlife and wildlife is being
pressured to blah blah blah that is
going to result in pathogens that
normally circulate amongst wild animals
making a zoonotic jump to people at
which point boom and then you come up
with some really crazy level of fear
about what type of pathogen could
suddenly emerge and not be controllable
and therefore why it is absolutely
essential that every
god-fearing mask-wearing grant-giving
agency has to deliver a huge amount of
money to these people who are the only
ones to study the pathogen before it
leaps out of a cave and gets us all yeah
because what will probably be obvious
but might not be known to people is that
every grant application
um that i have ever seen and i saw a ton
of them back when i spent a year working
with the grant agency university of
california at santa cruz many years ago
but have since seen and heard about many
many others is that um
yes they are supposed to be assessed on
their scientific merits but there is a
section of every single one and as i
remember it actually many grant
applications begin and end
with versions of that same section and
that section is basically explain why
you deserve money
which is not the same as explain why
this is good science well and so there
you know their needs they hopefully
there is good science in the stuff that
is being funded but the decision to fund
is based in part and it's got to be
largely given that it's bracketing
almost every grant application you know
why what is it about your work that
demands funding now which means
increasing the sense of urgency uh is
more likely to get you funding right and
so it effectively is smoke and mirrors
boilerplate and the basic point is
either the people reviewing the grant
are in on why this isn't exactly true
but they're not going to call it out
because they're in the same business or
they can't see through it because they
don't have the expertise that would tell
them why that's a [ __ ] story right
you know human beings expanding and
coming into more and more contact with
wildlife
[ __ ]
right now it happens there are more
people and it happens we are backing the
wild farther and farther away but people
coming into contact with wildlife is the
entire history of people right which
means most of the things that can make
an easy jump have done it a higher
proportion of the human population was
always in more contact with wildness
then the proportion of the human
population that is in contact with
wildness is now right and
viewers may be interested to go back to
my unheard essay where i as a former bat
biologist this is a different one than
you referenced earlier yeah i as a
former bat biologist go through the
question at the point that covid emerges
into the world i then have to wonder if
being in contact with bats is enough to
unleash a pandemic like this could i
have accidentally done it when i was in
contact with bats and the answer is very
likely not that this is actually a
difficult evolutionary jump
and that there you know you have lots of
people you have thousands of people
studying bats at any one time
we're not constantly causing pandemics
why is that and the answer is because
the thing that they say at the beginning
of those grant applications about the
danger of this happening on any given
tuesday right that's [ __ ] designed
to get the system to spit out money
that's right and so okay
in light of all that you've got the
[ __ ] designed to get the system to
spit out money it spits out money to
fund a reckless kind of research that is
very likely to do exactly the thing that
nature is not well poised to do right
it's very likely to unleash a pathogen
into the world
yeah is it this one okay um so
you might just suck
let dad keep talking but um just put on
the screen for a moment and i'll post in
the show notes too go for it so in
effect you've got
a difficult evolutionary leap
that a pathogen would have to make in
order to become a human pandemic then
you have
humans who are clever but not that
clever proposing to do exactly the thing
that will make it a small evolutionary
leap right they're proposing to use
uh trampolines and catapults to get the
thing across the gap to become
capable of in of creating a pandemic on
the basis of the absurd argument that in
order to know what to do about a
pandemic we're going to have to create
something that's capable of making one
which of course runs the risk that the
thing is going to leap into the
the world at any moment because lab
accidents are not uncommon at all
and so okay so then the question is well
what about the people frankly like sam
harris who
said uh well you know i i wasn't i sam
wasn't animated about the question of
lab leaks because at some level it's an
academic question we've got this virus
what's the best way to deal with it
and the answer is no this makes all the
difference in the world because what in
effect is going on if you think back to
the natural origins paper the christian
anderson lead paper
so christian anderson interacted with
fouchy
behind closed doors
in his email
anderson
argued that in fact the viruses they
were coming to know it was inconsistent
with evolutionary theory it could not
have come about naturally and
effectively a plan emerges to obscure
that and suddenly there's a reversal of
course and anderson and
his academic cronies cook up a paper
that says this virus has to have come
from nature it couldn't have come from
the lab and here's how you know and
their argument is nonsense their
argument is
we
would not have known that the structure
we see would be any good at infecting
people therefore we wouldn't have
planned it this way if people were going
to make a virus they wouldn't have made
this one which is true
what they didn't say
was that there's another mechanism that
we're not that good at doing things like
describing a virus that's going to
infect people but what we're really good
at doing is borrowing tools from nature
right we borrow enzymes to do genetic
engineering we borrow antibiotics to
fight off bacteria we borrow evolution
to solve problems we are not smart
enough to solve yet and so serial
passaging was the thing that they were
avoiding describing in that manuscript
right so they do not say what we're
going to do or what likely has accounted
for the existence of this virus is that
the virus ancestor virus was passed from
one individual to another
evolving along the way to answer the
question how would you make a pathogen
for humans if you don't know enough to
specify its molecular nature
so
what that in effect
does is it creates a virus with the
characteristics that the people who ran
the experiments wanted it to have
but it also has other characteristics so
at the same time they were selecting
for uh the capacity to infect human
tissues they were also selecting for
what i would call explorer modes they
were selecting for a virus that was
experimenting
furthermore if you think about the
question of what virus we ended up with
you know you and i heather have been
very careful
not to fall into the trap of saying this
isn't a dangerous virus
right from the beginning we talked about
the fact that actually this is quite a
scary virus and that the level of uh
danger is not captured in the
comparatively low case fatality rate
right there seems to be lots of harm
done
around the body that isn't captured
there which
you know my telomere work suggests is
going to accelerate aging and shorten
lives
so
so then the point is
is anything about what makes this virus
actually dangerous
uh the result of the mechanism used to
generate it
and um
the point of the point i want to make is
let's say that you used ferrets which
have an ace2 receptor similar to humans
in order to get evolution to solve the
question of how you take a virus poorly
adapted to infect
humans
the ancestor
virus to cyrus kov2 and get it to be
really good at infecting humans so
ferrets are likely serial passage
organism
so called humanized mice mice that have
been altered so they are molecularly
more similar to humans are a likely
place for serial passage and human
airway tissue
which can be purchased and basically uh
uses evolution to solve the question of
how to get from cell to cell
in human airways so all of these things
are places where evolution could have
been used to solve this puzzle but what
will happen let's take the ferret
example
in nature
a virus that infects a
ferret
needs to leave the ferret capable of
doing ferret stuff in order for the
ferret to spread the virus to others
otherwise the you know remember the are
not term how uh
you know how many cases can an
individual case
spur if if a ferret is only capable of
infecting its you know
family members in the borough and it's
not going to encounter other ferrets in
the population and neither are they
right then are not is going to be less
than one and the thing will go extinct
that's not a successful plan so the
point is
there's certain pathogens that don't
work this way malaria for example knocks
you flat on your ass why because you're
not spreading it mosquitoes are so you
being so the analysis is different with
a vectored pathogen right because if
you're lying down and you can't swat a
mosquito then the mosquito is in a good
position to pick it up and move it and
the analysis will be different uh with
the waterborne
waterborne and you know as everyone you
know became familiar with and probably
mostly forgot the difference it's going
to be different for aerosol eyes versus
airborne yeah um for you know foam light
transmission you know mode of
transmission vector versus not all of
these are going to have different
predictions
um that come along with them about
whether or not you expect virulence to
evolve
to be a pathogen to become more violent
over time in a population or less
population density of course as well
so
if you're going to use
laboratory serial passaging yep
what you are doing is you are actually
creating a route that the pathogen
couldn't go through in nature
and i would just point
to several features of this virus
that are probably far worse by
virtue of the fact
that serial passaging is the likely
explanation for where they came from
critically
if a pathogen in order to get from one
individual to the next let's say a
respiratory pathogen requires you to be
mobile so you can't be terribly sick
right then trade-offs being what they
are
it has an incentive not to do any damage
to tissue that isn't directly involved
in transmission
right to the extent that you have
tissues that aren't capable of spreading
the virus
because they're not exposed to the
outside world and everybody who
contracts the virus is getting it
from a respiratory source then the point
is well that reduces your mobility
without increasing transmissibility so
nature wouldn't do that on the other
hand
if you've got ferrets caged together
where they don't have to find each other
and they don't have to you know look
healthy right imagine you know creatures
in nature are liable to have a revulsion
for individuals of their species who
look sickly right it's natural that you
would evolve that um because of course
not every sickly individual has
something transmissible but a lot of
them do yeah and so sickly individuals
are something to be avoided but if
you're caged with a sickly individual
your preference to avoid them doesn't
matter because you can't avoid them so
lots of things about this maybe even
anosmia
right to the extent that a ferret in
order not to starve to death has to
depend on its extraordinary sense of
smell
right a virus that disrupts that
extraordinary sense of smell is
immediately going to cause a uh a
foraging problem for a ferret yeah but
not in a not in a cage where the ferret
eats ferret kibble right
so you could get things like an osmia
which wouldn't naturally be likely to
happen because the ferret needs to be
ecologically capable yeah so interesting
i mean that so
there might be two different possible
approaches like an osmia might be
adaptive in this situation and not in a
you know a normal ferret situation or um
and this seems far more likely the one
that you've proposed
inosemia might be
acceptable and not come with a normal
cost in the situation that it would in a
wild ferret population right exactly in
this case anosmia is annoying it's not
obvious that it has long-term
implications but the point is it does
seem conspicuous right much like a virus
that can only be transmitted indoors
well that also seems like an arbitrary
uh laboratory phenomenon potentially
that that one strikes me more like it's
about effective volume and
you know i think most
most viruses that are sort of airborne
aerosolized are going to at least have a
strong
be much more likely to transmit indoors
although the degree to which that is
true for this one does seem extreme no i
i agree that they will it'll be more
likely for any respiratory virus that is
not
transmitted but the degree to which it
is true in this virus is conspicuous for
something that supposedly
came from the wild yeah and of course
the point is trade-offs are under all of
this so if you can borrow from outdoor
transmission without a cost because
you're
in caged animals then you will tend to
borrow in that and you will get
something on some other characteristic
that you know we don't know the two are
connected yep um but anyway my and you
know this one it may be that the
laboratory origin actually worked for us
because it left the outside environment
a place that one could actually be safe
if not for bad cdc advice and things
like that
well but
but for the laboratory origin we
wouldn't have it at all so you know
you don't want to go down that road too
far you can't you can i started by
saying
uh if laboratory origin then effectively
you've got everything down everything
downstream it belongs on their bill yes
even worse to the extent that people
then took a crisis that we could
potentially have ended if we had behaved
in a coordinated and smart fashion and
decided to utilize it for other purposes
yes right people made bank
well not even made bank the point is
huma
let's say that this was
a mild disease let's say that this was
somewhere between cold and flu okay
the cost to humanity in fact even the
number of deaths is incalculable if
you're stuck with it forever
right and so the point is the costs of
even if that was it even if that was it
yeah you know okay we had flu and now we
got another one right yeah that is a
disaster and for anyone to have used
this for their own purposes
and at the same time run out the clock
that that was running on us actually
controlling the thing is uh
you know
it's it's diabolical
yeah and i um
go on okay so let me let me just close
this out so you've got various
characteristics that may
you know these are hypotheses may be
connected to serial passaging in a
laboratory environment that is not like
nature one of them is the exploratory
nature of this uh
pathogen right the tropism for different
tissues
is uh high and it may even be that its
ability to jump species is high because
it's been run through you know some
training courses
um tropism you're using in a way that is
that i'm not familiar with
it's a different definition than in
botany although maybe it's it's an
affiliation for yeah effectively right
right okay
so phototropic the tendency to seek the
light tropism in this case means its
ability to affect different tissues in
effect there is a constraint on a
natural virus don't infect tissues that
don't help spread the virus so that you
leave the animal as healthy as possible
so it can go around and do the spreading
in this case if you've got you know
animals caged so that they don't have to
be any good at being animals right
they're just cellular environments then
you lift a constraint and the question
is is part of the
large number of tissues that seem to be
negatively impacted by this virus the
result of the fact that it was in a
highly unusual circumstance in which
animals couldn't get away from each
other
um
if that's what happened then the point
is much of the harm that comes to an
individual who gets sick with this may
be the result of its unnatural origin
and so right in effect all of the
explanations that say look
okay
if it came from a lab we need to know
that so it doesn't happen again but
short of that none of this matters no it
all matters and what you really need are
people who are uh
informed enough and uh
insulated from the incentives that they
can actually have a conversation about
how much harm came to humanity
from which errors right and the errors
just continued to compound
well or you could make the founder of
ecohealth alliance the lead on the
investigation of what the origin of
sarsko v2 was for the trip to china i
mean that seems like there's no conflict
there no you could just tell him that
he's got a new job and his new job is to
find out whether this came from the lab
and i'm sure he would you know his new
job is to see if he's a criminal in a
past life which is to say a current life
this is cool
this is this is next next level uh
criminal investigation where the people
who do the investigation are the people
who are in the best position to do it by
virtue of the fact that they committed
the crime and therefore they're in
nearly complete possession of the
information necessary to
to prosecute it's beautiful yeah i mean
it's almost meritorious
excellent
[Music]
you